hey guys welcome back to ET I'm Deidre
Behar here with Vanderpump rules star
Stassi Schroeder and she's gonna show us
what is in her purse yeah okay show us
the gorgeous bag what is this by the way
this is amazing
it's a Chloe drew bag oh it's my
favorite bag that's ever been designed
so I like it's my splurge to like get
these in different colors it's it's
pretty perfect and it's very you it's
very saucy Thanks
so what's in there this cool little
hairbrush thing of course it's gold yeah
and of course there's nasty hair all
over it car keys wallet amazing all
black and gold may I add so cute my
little pink house key this is for your
house yes so chic oh my goodness good
girl you are doing something right you
know what I have terrible credit so when
I was approved for my Mercedes six
months ago he didn't come in and say
congratulations you've been approved for
a car mind you just took two days to get
approved he came in he's like
congratulations your credits about to
get so good and I started crying happy
tears
I wasn't even excited about the car as
much as I was excited about my credit
getting yes I'm so proud of you were
growing up this is the color I'm wearing
today on my lips okay Makeup Forever
aqua lip 3c and it gives you that
perfect like mauve pink tone I overlined
my lips - do you use it as a lipstick as
well do you fill your lip in with it
yeah oh wow this little makeup forever
this powder this little baby
yeah so that I don't get shiny
especially during the summer when we're
filming I have to have this at all time
okay that's a must
this in case I mean a boy that I'm gonna
want to make out with weed chapstick
it's explain what it's cherry lip balm
but it has CBD in it it doesn't make you
high or anything it's good for you it's
hydrating it's good for you you know
when you put on like a cream like people
who have like skin problems like when
they put like marijuana in the actual
lotion doesn't make you high it just is
good for your skin this little yellow
pile because I have a really bad habit
where I pick my jowls over oh this cute
little pen
cuz you never know when you're gonna
need to write a check cuz I'm classy I
keep Frankie's because when I do my
makeup sometimes when I do smokey eye
I feel like this and then I put the eye
shadow over it so that I get like a wing
and then I just have a bunch of quarters
amazing yeah you've got literally all
the essentials that you need right there
right
it looks so ratchet all together by the
way this is a Huntsman winters war nail
file
yeah well meat cake is Katie because of
Katie's blog we a pucker & pout we went
to like a screening of it it's for her
blog
anyway they gave a swag and I might
actually like really like this one
amazing ride or die with the Huntsman
ride or die with any Hemsworth yeah
that's 100% accurate
Olli Mr Chris Chris oh I'm Leon good
this is why we're for everyone yes
amazing hey guys thanks for watching ET
on YouTube now there's plenty more where
that came from just click the subscribe
button wherever it is click it